today we're talking about webgl powered
maps features
machine learning deployment acceleration
and pi
i'm daryl ducharme and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
in 2019 we calculated 31.4 trillion
digits of pi a world record at the time
then in 2021 scientists at the
university of applied sciences of the
gree zones calculated another 31.4
trillion digits of the constant
bringing the total up to 62.8 trillion
decimal places
today we're announcing yet another
record 100 trillion digits
this is the second time we've used
google cloud to calculate a record
number of digits tripling it in just
three years due to the constant
improvements in google cloud
infrastructure
learn more about how we did it on the
blog
at last year's google i o our team
announced the preview release of a set
of new webgl powered maps features for
the maps javascript api
these features give you unprecedented
control of the vector base map as part
of the customization and styling options
available with cloud-based map styling
now generally available all this is made
possible thanks to the native webgl apis
that are supported in all modern
browsers giving access to the rendering
power of the device gpu so you can
create performant beautiful maps
experiences never before possible with
maps javascript api
head to the blog to see demos use cases
and more
during our applied machine learning
summit we announced a variety of product
features and technology partnerships to
help you more quickly and efficiently
build deploy manage and maintain machine
learning models in production
our performance tests found a 2.5 x
increase in the number of ml predictions
generated through vertex ai and bigquery
in 2021
and a 25x increase in active customers
for vertex ai workbench in just the last
six months
take a look at the blog post to see how
our announcements will help you remove
the barriers to deploying useful and
predictable machine learning at scale
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud